indeed second place in the st louis
rabbit and blitz say can place typhos i
can hear fabi i know you played to win
tournaments not to come in second
but you've had a great summer so far
yeah i i mean i feel just a bit
disappointed at the moment but uh
but i guess overall okay it was a bit up
and down but the tournament
had some bright moments so that's good
uh your thoughts about
uh
the the tour itself
you had a a couple of results earlier
that you might have wanted to get back a
little bit more
yeah i started very badly um i really
pretty much doomed myself with the
with the tournaments in bucharest in
paris uh
i mean i i already was like basically
writing the tour off
somehow i still had some chance at a
placement uh
um if i had you know
had a little bit of a better result in
this tournament
and i had my chances to to do that
um then i i would have gotten third
place i guess which is not
um
i mean it's not like it's a spectacular
result or anything but but it would have
been a nice consolation
your thoughts about how maxine performed
in this event
yeah max team played great i mean it was
also impressive how he bounced back he
had a tough game against linear um
i mean a great game by all by all means
uh lanier played an amazing game um but
it must have been tough for maxime and
and he took it in stride i mean after
that he
uh he scored plus two after that so in
any case he he uh
he played extremely well throughout he
won a lot of games so so kudos to him
what about wesley's performance he was a
solid plus two enough to win him the
grand chesterwood title
yeah he he was all around um very solid
and stable
and he won paris convincingly so
so well deserved victory for him
uh what's next for you upcoming next
couple of events
i think there's the
i don't know exactly what it's called
but it's just nine like chess nine alex
yeah the fisher random
uh tournament um that's coming up that's
gonna be my next event and then the us
championship after that
um which will be exciting i
i didn't have a chance to play the the
us championship which was held online
last year
um
and so it's been two years since i
played the us championship and that now
will be in person which is uh
which is even more fun
that's an important tournament for you i
mean you won it once
seemed like you won it the first time
you played but you haven't won one since
it's it's a tough championship to win
yeah it's tough uh i had some subpar
results and then i had one in 2018 i
thought i played a
pretty much a great tournament but then
sam
[Music]
ran away with it uh i think i was plus
five and it wasn't enough um
so
so yeah i'm hoping to to make a mark
this time
and final question your thoughts about
the brilliancy prize for this tournament
that that game that you won
would it be among the question is would
it be among your your best games
in your career if you had to do a best
games book no no that's the wrong answer
that was a trick question
did you not get any malice from that
question he's an honest job
you see that that's why we love and
respect fabi and uh yeah exactly and
that's why i picked you to win the
tournament as well see he has your guy
has no kind of loyalty
excuse me who won the tournament can we
get those predictions up anytime soon
you see this you got to talk to this guy
no no i i have to be i have to be
straight up on this one it was it was a
satisfying game but it wasn't uh close
to one of my best um
uh but i did tell you that it would be
my best chance at the brilliancy project
i wasn't wrong about that the first
round
wow
all right well
thanks so much for joining us and uh
good luck with the chest 90x thank you
quick quick question for you pappy this
today's game
it was rather a controlled affair i
might even say kind of a dull affair
until the position rather exploded
after the move f7 f5 by yourself your
opponent played the move c5
d5 and the position really kind of blew
up from here exciting things happened
tough tough tough big fight draw in the
end uh take us through your mindset what
was going through your mind at this
point were you ambitious
uh yeah i was i was very ambitious
um i saw that if he doesn't play f4 then
he's
he's basically getting uh steamrolled
with d4 and uh e4 and everything coming
in the center
so f4 unfortunately uh
he has but still i thought that
i have chances here and um
and then i i mean i own i felt like i
was pretty much winning at some point
like
i know i know that's not the case
because uh
i was told after the game but there was
nothing
but it's really
very very close to being tactically
winning
um because he is i mean his king is so
weak
um
because like here i have nothing after
rook t5 that was basically
telling him
uh
well i mean i had no time to really
think uh telling him okay you know play
rook fd3 and we'll make a draw soon
and then
uh richard shocked me because he started
to play for a win with h5 which is i
think pretty much crazy move
uh and
like this is is borderline losing it's
um
it's only holding because he has this
rookie one move
if rook f3
rook one f3 then queenie e4 wins i mean
i'm mating him and i have a past d pawn
so
i think this wins maybe maybe to
something
so rookie won't only move and the end
game is also borderline losing so
i even had
i the reason i spent time here was
because i have queen e1
queen d4 d2
so he has to play rook t5 where i
promote
and it looks crazy but i have to move
rookie 7 here um with a threat of d1
queen i'm in queen h4 rookie one
and queen d3 rookie four is winning
uh and he has i think only one move
which is which is queen g4
unfortunately not only does it
uh save the game it might also win the
game so
wow
wow
but yeah i i had a feeling that the end
game was actually winning but i was told
that it wasn't
nifty nifty piece of calculation there
fabi thank you for sharing your thoughts
and really i thought you played a great
tournament and
found some nice form thank you well done
yeah congratulations fabi tied for
second place in this event